today we are checking out the world's
first 16-inch qhd gaming laptop this is
the lenovo legion 7.
a huge thank you to lenovo legion and
microsoft for sponsoring this video
[Music]
you guys i am so
so so so excited to show you guys this
laptop i know we do a ton of laptop
videos here but this is a pre-production
unit of the lenovo legion 7 16 inch so
this really is the first look that we're
getting at this device so i've been
using this all this past week and it's
honestly so incredible this 16-inch
display is so perfect for gaming it has
165 hertz refresh rate and an extra wide
16 by 10 aspect ratio this has an 8 core
amd ryzen 9 5900 hx mobile processor
which will give you high frame rates
while not compromising battery life with
the nvidia geforce rtx 3060 graphics
card we'll be getting a huge upgrade in
graphics performance as well one thing i
love so much about this laptop is the
fact that it is so portable so i really
can game basically anywhere it's not
often that you get a laptop that's this
small and portable that's this powerful
you can also spec this out with up to
two terabytes of storage and up to 32
gigs of ram one feature that makes a
huge difference in performance is the
lenovo legion ai engine now this is
exclusive to lenovo legion laptops and
it's a series of ai solutions that will
dynamically shift power between the cpu
and the gpu for more frames per second
on your favorite games basically they're
just kind of making it really easy for
us to overclock this
so no gaming laptop review would be
complete without actually gaming on it
and one of the things that i love about
having a laptop that i can game on is of
course i can connect a controller so i
have an xbox controller all hooked up to
this but i used to travel a lot i would
always bring a controller with me so i
would be gaming on the plane i would be
gaming in hotel rooms i cannot wait to
start traveling again because this
laptop will definitely be coming with me
also i'm very excited about and i've
talked about this in many different
videos before is the xbox game pass it's
always being updated with new games so
it's a really great subscription service
if you want to just play a bunch of
different games and have access to new
ones all the time right now i'm gonna
play forza this is a park xbox game pass
so let's
freaking race shall we these speakers on
this thing
are actually pretty impressive as well
motorsport series
[Music]
for decades it's drawn the racing
world's best
beep beep goodbye
my friends so far while gaming i've been
really impressed with the performance
we're hardly having any dropped frames
everything is running so smoothly bp
move out of the way and the fact this is
all running on a laptop wow i'm so shook
this is incredible
15th cool uh we don't have to talk about
that
oh no it's raining i'm not ready to be
driving in these elements oh i'm
slipping and sliding all over this track
i just pushed that car all the way off
into the grass
holy moly i have crashed
my
vehicle we're we're riding together
we're best friends
we ended that race
actually together
far cry new dawn installed ready to go
oh i love this game i'm so excited
already to start playing oh this would
be great i mean this is running
really smoothly
oh shoot
she wasn't ready
oh hey
get out of here i'm freeing my friends
no don't jump off there you're going to
die you have fallen go to the river we
got to go to the river look how pretty
this is
like the graphics like everything look
it's look at this water oh
hi
are you
yep you're you're strapped to that
look at the hummingbirds oh it makes me
so happy
we need more duct tape
check out the corner
[Music]
what do you think i'm doing
yeah get him get him get him get him oh
my gosh i'm dying
all right so i played a little bit of
far cry i definitely plan on playing
this game
a lot more playing some halo for my
third and final gaming test this has
been running so smooth and normally when
you're gaming on a laptop sometimes i do
feel like there is some performance
hindrance because you are gaming on a
mobile device but this has been running
very
very smooth i'm very impressed you guys
do not stand a chance with my impeccable
aim
and talent we gotta go kids
let's roll
bye
bye friend
let's freaking go is anybody going to
drive with me does somebody else want to
drive or is this or am i in charge now
where's all my friends at have i left
them have i left my friends behind
so gaming on this thing was just an
absolute delight like i don't even know
how else to explain it because this
screen is incredible having this 16 by
10 aspect ratio really does give you a
lot more screen real estate and you
don't really realize it until you're
actually in the game and playing the 165
hertz refresh rate also absolutely
incredible like everything about this
just is amazing normally when you're
gaming on a laptop i feel like there is
some performance loss but i was playing
some pretty processor intensive games on
this thing i barely heard the fans and i
feel like i was not dropping frames and
everything was running really really
well i also really love the keyboard
just the travel on the keys it's like a
very soft type just the overall design
of this thing like it just looks cool i
like that they have the logo up here on
the side so it kind of just leaves this
whole thing open and clean i love the
design of the air vents on the side like
there are so many things that i
absolutely just
love about this it's just
i'm speechless it's incredible
the colors on it are also really great
with best-in-class color accuracy and
high dynamic range i've also been doing
a lot of photo editing in addition to
gaming so it's always nice to know that
i'm getting the most accurate colors
possible one of the things that i love
about this laptop is you're not going to
need a dongle there are so many ports on
this that you should be set for whatever
you need to do i also like that a lot of
the ports are on the back including the
power adapter i'm so used to having
power cables on the left or the right
side and normally that's where i would
have my mouse if i'm gaming and i'm also
left-handed so if i'm using like a
stylus or something that's also over
here so there's just cords everywhere i
like that it's all nice and compact in
the back on the right we have a usbc and
also this electronic shutter button this
allows you to electronically disconnect
your webcam from the board so if privacy
is something that you're concerned about
with the webcam they've got you covered
on the left side we have a usbc and 3.5
millimeter headphone jack on the back we
have three usb type a's one usbc hdmi
ethernet and your power adapter i'm
really into the rgb lighting inside the
vents and along the body of the laptop
as well as the keyboard and even on the
logo plus it's fully customizable using
the corsair iq app and obviously i'm
gonna make it pink
[Music]
in the iq app you can customize every
single light that is on this thing
including the keyboard like you can
click and change the colors of all of
the keys you can select all of them and
basically have a rainbow party you can
also choose from a bunch of different
lighting effects you have your rainbow
wave
color shift
color pulse
color wave
visor
rain
i think that's my favorite
oh this one's pretty too
[Music]
there's also the option to choose data
colors
oh look at that pink nice
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video again a
huge thank you to lenovo legion and
microsoft for sponsoring this video if
you guys want to get more info or to
purchase this laptop i will put a link
in the description and i'll see you guys
in the next video bye
[Music]
you